depuis six mois les étudiants de
sciences po paris écoulent leurs
sentiments avec ce distributeur de
chewing gum et ce grâce à un jeu ni ni
mon teint lui-même en master a lieu paix
qui ne savaient pas quoi faire de ses
pièces rouges
le pièce rouge aujourd'hui il y en a
beaucoup et il y en a beaucoup trop dire
qu'on s'en rend pas forcément compte
mais il y en a 60 milliards dans qui
circulent dans l'union européenne serait
à peu près 120 par habitant est délirant
et en plus ces pièces là ne se recyclent
pas dans les circuits économiques
c'est également un gaspillage vraiment
de d'argent propre parce que frapper une
pièce rouge
l opération qui se fait à perdre ça
coûte 3 centimes donc ça coûte cher vous
voyons pour frapper les pièces de 1 et
de 5 1 et 2 centimes pas les 5 les liens
et de surtout on perd de l'argent c'est
le contribuable paye pour lancer sa
petite entreprise
benjamin du pays 22 ans a bénéficié
d'une bourse de 30 mille euros du
conseil régional
mais c'est en inde qu'il a trouvé ses
fournisseurs difficile de convaincre
banks et professionnelle en france
moi je suis reparti la fleur au fusil en
disant je vais choisir singapour c'est
une destination asiatique très
occidentalisée ça va être bien
je suis confronté à singapour au même
prix qu'en france c'est à dire que les
lébous opérateurs de distribution
automatique sur le très grosses
structures qui n'écoutent pas vraiment
les personnes qui ont un petit projet
j'ai dû voyager au sein même de l'asie
donc je suis retrouvé en inde assez
rapidement qui était la destination dans
laquelle à mon avis
avait le plus d'opportunités simplement
parce que le tissu économique indien est
beaucoup plus pas déstructurer mais à
plus petite échelle en fait une centaine
de machines doit être livré courant
octobre benjamin du pays compte se
développer sur le marché universitaire
et celui des transports ainsi que dans
le milieu de l'entreprise comme à la
pépinière promo paul de montigny deux
personnes devraient être embauchées en
renfort le jeune il y monte un rêve des
tendances son modèle à toute l'europe et
avec d'autres produits dont le prix de
vente n'excédera pas cinq centimes
d'euro